foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled boosting signal to noise
in single cell rna-seq through molecular
depletion
this webinar is a part of the 10th
Annual genetics virtual week
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
jump code genomics
for more information about jump code
genomics go to jumpcodegenomics.com
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
First participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker
Dante Dias canas research associate two
research and development sub code
genomics
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dante you may now
begin your presentation
hi everyone my name is Dante Dias canis
and I'm a research associate too here at
johncogenomics and today I'm going to be
talking with everyone about how we can
improve the signal to noise ratio in
single cell RNA seek data using one of
our products called crispr clean
the official name of our product is
called the crisper clean single cell RNA
boost kit for those of you that want to
check it out on our website that's where
you'll find it and that's what the name
of this product will be under
so before I get started in this
presentation I just want to give a brief
background onto why single cell rna-seq
is useful and why people are starting to
use it more
um and for example one main aspect of
why it's why it's useful is that
conventional bulk R and seek methods
only really provide an average
expression across the sample type
whereas using single cell rna-seq we can
actually sequence the gene expression
profiles of individual cells and as a
result be able to find some newer or
rare cell type populations that may
exist in a heterogeneous tissue or
sample that we otherwise might not have
been able to discover by using bulk
rna-seq methods while that's not only
limited to that for the talk today we're
going to mainly focus on how using our
product and using the crispr clean can
really enhance the identification of
cell types within heterogeneous sample
while single cell rna-seq has become a
useful technique in recent times
it does not come without its own
limitations and one of the main
limitations of single cell rna-seq is
how the noise confounds the biological
interpretation so if we look here on the
left what we've shown here is how the
poor capture efficiency perk on a per
cell basis influences the data as a
result we can see that in reality using
a droplet-based method per cell you only
capture about 10 to 20 percent at Max of
the actual transcripts within that cell
and as a result if we transition to the
right to the right in the middle here we
can see that compared to bulk samples
the single cell data is sparse and
contains a lot of zeros in the data not
being able to capture as many
transcripts as you would otherwise in a
bulk or an AC sample
therefore
allowing to the idea here if we look to
the right all the way on the right here
how this noise is quote unquote
pervasive meaning that if we take two
cell types that are supposed to be very
similar between one another and we plot
them together on an X Y graph
the capture of those Gene Expressions
should be very similar but in reality
what we see is that they're very
different and we get what's called
Dropout events some over dispersion and
some outliers and that the r squared
value between those two cells is very
low as a result there is a need to try
and reduce that noise and get as much
biological interpretation that we can
out of the single cell data
so here I would like to give a brief
overview of the crispr clean workflow
and how it can be used in the 10x
workflow as well to essentially reduce
noise in rna-seq data so what we can do
is we can actually use crispr to digest
unwanted sequences if we look here on
the left anything in denoted in purple
is a sequence of this interest or a
sequence that we don't want in our final
Library we can use crispr to digest it
consequently we can do a size selection
step to remove those short fragments and
only PCR amplify the fragments of
interest that we want in our final
Library
and what's great about this is that it
fits very nicely within the 10x droplet
workflow and only adds an additional two
hours of time with the 45 minutes of
Hands-On time in the workflow
so before going into the presentation
any further I would like to give you
guys an outline and exactly what's going
to be covered in this presentation
um and the first thing we're going to be
going over is a proof of concept using
cardiovascular samples and essentially
what we're aiming to do here is assess
whether or not the sample heterogeneity
can be captured using crispr clean
technology and therefore from there use
in Silicon modeling using publicly
available data identify what are things
that we could Target using this
technology to further enhance the being
the reads being redistributed and
finally tied in all together
assess the application using immune
samples and how we can further identify
cell types
so what I would like to highlight here
is how single cell rna-seq only utilizes
the raise outline to the transcriptome
so what I mean by this is how
if we look at the bar in green we can
see that these represent the total reads
that come off the sequencer so we have
all of our reads which represent a
hundred percent here after we take those
reads we align them confidently to the
genome and we can see that 90
approximately 90 of those reads align
confidently to the genome on average and
from there we take that genome alignment
and then we'll use a popular method such
as cell Ranger which is standard in the
10x workflow
as we can see on average approximately
five somewhere between 50 and 60 percent
of the reads that align to the genome
therefore align to the transcriptome
and those reads are what is therefore
being used for Downstream processing
so in reality you're only capturing
about half the information
um off from the from the reads that you
get off the sequencer for Downstream
processing
and so you might be asking yourself well
how can we actually make
um this better or get more
transcriptional information out of this
well what we've noticed is that even
though we're only taking polyadenylated
transcripts in the 10x workflow and
advertently some ribosomal RNA
transcripts do get do get captured and
mapped to the genome
additionally there are polyadenylated
ribosomal and mitochondrial protein
coding genes that get aligned to the
transcriptome as well but those genes
are less informative and don't
contribute to much in the down as much
in the downstream analysis as a result
these make for easy targets for us to be
able to deplete because they also make
together approximately 30 36 percent of
the total reads in the data as a result
we sh by depleting those reads from the
libraries we can therefore redistribute
them to other informative transcripts
and therefore boost our biological
interpretation
here I would like to highlight how we
can directly compare our depletion
protocol with that of the standard 10x
workflow so at the top we can see here
we have our channels so each coronary
and Pulmonary represents a different set
of channels that was run through the 10x
chip
from there we take our Amplified cdna
and we split that cdna at the WTA step
and we either proceed with the standard
10x workflow or the depletion not
explicitly highlighted here but I want
to stress that we're actually taking the
same from the same channel and from the
same WTA splitting that between to
proceed with the standard 10x workflow
and that to depletion type of direct
comparison of the same cell population
and at the same from the same cdna as a
result we then proceed either with the
the 10x workflow or depletion and with
our depletion using our ribosomal RNA
and ribosomal mitochondrial protein
coding to eliminate those transcripts
from the from our final library and
therefore process and further sequencing
what I would like to do now is focus
your attention here to the bar graphs on
the left and what we have shown for you
here is how the reads have been
redistributed once coming off the
sequencer so out of 100 total reads in
the in the top grouping or cohort that
we have of each replicate of each
coronary versus pulmonary cell type we
can see that after depletion we see
percent read that are aligning to the
transcriptome is approximately about 70
percent of reads however if we compare
that to either a mock treated sample or
a control the control meaning a standard
10x workflow we see that we're actually
getting a redistribution of what we
expect or hypothesized which is about 50
however the key takeaway here is that
with depletion just in terms of
informative transcript transcript
alignment we get a boost to about 70
percent of reads constantly mapping to
the transcriptome which is great as a
result out of 50 back at approximately
57 000 uh reads per shell depletion were
able to recover over 200 more genes per
cell more umis per cell as well as more
genes that are contributing to
biological signal therefore allowing for
more biological interpretation
Downstream
the first thing that I would like to
highlight here from this from this
figure is that again we are working and
I would like to reiterate that we are
working with endothelial samples so
going in we are working with one major
cell type so as we can see looking at
these umap plots and again just to
get everybody on the same page a umat
plot is just a two-dimensional
representation of the differences and
similarities of cells in transcriptional
space
so as we can see we only get one major
one major cell type here with many
different cell types or sub clusters or
sub cell types existing within that one
major one
now the second point and the other thing
I would like to mention here highlight
is the fact that how
proceeding with depletion we're not
negatively impacting that interpretation
again so after comparing between the
standard and depleted we should see only
one major cell type with many different
subtypes existing within that cell
population but net in as a result
depletion is not negatively impacting
that result
next I would like to talk about how
depletion is able to remove the
technical technical noise that would be
interpreted interpreted as a phenotypic
signal so what's interesting here is if
I take
the umap plot from the standard and
depleted and do different from gene
expression and compare we see some
different results
so if we focus your attention here to
the left if we take a umap plot of the
standard and again each color represents
a different subcluster within the main
cell type and if I just pick one at
random pick this orange Sub sub cluster
here and do a differential gene
expression we can see that we have some
very highly significant genes associated
with the differential gene expression
that are being up and down regulated in
this case
however if I compare that to depleted
and take that same sub cell type and do
the differential gene expression we can
see that those same genes are not as
highly differentially expressed so what
does that mean what that means is that
we've essentially removed the technical
noise and we've increased
the the capture of some of the lowly
expressed transcripts therefore reducing
that technical noise however it's not
affecting our biological interpretation
in this case because we're still
identifying it as a different subcluster
but we get a better accurate and more
accurate representation of the
differential gene expression between
clusters as a result
again I would just like to highlight
here and just reiterate the notion of
how depletion is able to remove the
technical noise that would be
interpreted the phenotypic signal so if
we look at the standard here and look at
a different subcluster of cells and do
the differential gene expression we see
a similar pattern where we see some very
highly differentially expressed genes
now why might that be the case well it
as we've shown before with the depletion
we get more ulis per cell we get more
genes per cell so the reason that these
genes are being so highly differentially
expressed is partly in due to the fact
that we're not capturing as many genes
of the lowly expressed genes however
with the depletion we're capturing more
of the lowly expressed genes giving a
more even distribution as a result
removing some of that technical noise
and getting a better interpretation of
the actually differentially expressed
genes in that sub type population
again we're just removing the noise here
and as a result but we're still keeping
the biological interpretation that these
are in fact different sub subtypes or
subclusters of cells within the main
cell type population
and so if you remember before these
endothelial samples actually consist of
both coronary and Pulmonary endothelial
cells one of the main goals of this is
we wanted to look at and capture using
our technology the differences in the
heterogeneity between these different
cell types now given they are both
endothelial samples we should see them
overlap very nicely now
given that the coronary and Pulmonary
will run on difference 10x channels we
have to implement a batch correction
method in order to do the downstream
analysis so if you look here on the left
we can see that if we look at our
standard and we compare the coronary
versus the pulmonary after batch
correction we see some differences here
so what I've highlighted here in circled
on the left is these two different types
of populations that are distinguishing
the coronary versus the pulmonary so
kind of more so directing to the fact
that
the batch correction here is less
efficient in the standard When comparing
the coronary and the pulmonary however
when looking at the depleted after
redistributing those reads were actually
gave better able to get a better idea of
what the transcriptional landscape is of
these coronary and Pulmonary cells of
these endothelial samples
as a result we see that after batch
correction we see a very nice overlap
between the coronary and the pulmonary
but we do see one distinct uh specific
phenotype that is unique to the coronary
epithelial cells further highlighting
the fact that with depletion we're able
to better Implement our batch correction
methods here while still
analyzing some heterogeneity and the
samples for further analysis to look at
the differences between coronary and
Pulmonary
rather than just looking at the U map
plus another way that we can actually
visualize the differences between the
coronary and the pulmonary here and
compare them between standard and
depleted is to look at hierarchical
clustering so if we take the top four
different difference up regulated genes
in the top four down regulated genes in
coronary versus pulmonary and do
hierarchical clustering compare and
compare them between each cluster and
the standard we can see that it's very
noisy and hard to interpret exactly
which cluster is being driven
exclusively the differences between the
coronary and the pulmonary
however if we take that and compare that
same thing to the depleted and do the
hierarchical clustering with the same
set of genes we can vary nicely very
beautifully see how we can actually
distinguish one major through the
hierarchical clustering one major cell
type that is actually being that is
actually driving the differences here
when we want to analyze the
heterogeneity and compare these
endothelial samples and find what's
different between coronary and Pulmonary
so without depletion we would have been
unable to really make an effective
interpretation of how these genes are
being affected in the clustering as a
result
and one thing we want to make sure is
that what we're seeing with depletion is
actually a relevant biological signal
right so what we've shown here is how
the depletion is able to enhance that
signal noise and clear clarify a
distinct phenotype subgroup of coronary
epithelial cells associated with plaque
so
you know if we do a gene set enrichment
analysis here and we can see that based
off of the genes that enrichment
analysis of that specific cluster and
look at those genes that are upregulated
in in that cluster we can see that these
genes are very highly associated with
biological processes that have been
shown in bulk rna-seq samples that are
involved in blood cell morphogenesis for
example in an extracellular structure
organization involved in these
endothelial samples and contributing the
coronary artery disease so all that
being said just AIDS or interpretation
that again the signal that we're seeing
is in fact biologically relevant and
AIDS to our understanding for further
analysis
and so with all that we're very nicely
able to show how we can use this
technology to effectively assess the
heterogeneity between samples however we
want to take that even further and see
can we actually increase the
biologically relevant information by by
looking at redistributing additional
reads rather than just looking at
ribosomal and mitochondrial genes
and looking at this same plot again that
we've shown before we want to ask the
main question where else can we pull
some non-informative reefs from so what
we can see here is that if we take
reason align to the genome that are not
used for analysis so besides ribosomal
RNA material that is still left in the
library what we find is that there are
some breeds that align to the genome
that do not align to the transcriptome
therefore being captured in our
libraries but are not being used for any
Downstream analysis now this could just
be due to the fact that these are
stretches of poly A's that are just
being captured and not having any but
therefore not have any informative
transcripts associated with them so
they're being filtered out nonetheless
they're still showing up in the data and
these are things that are not used for
analysis that we can easily Target
Target and increase our reads being
distributed to informative transcriptome
additionally some other things that we
can Target are what we would note as
non-variable genes so these are genes
that are typically housekeeping genes
that aren't used in any cell type
identification or genes that have any
that are not variable at all meaning
between cell types or between uh yeah
between cell types there's really no
difference in the amount of transcripts
detected therefore not being used in any
Downstream analysis so we can typically
those cells are filtered out anyway so
we can Target those non-variable genes
and therefore boost
reads being aligned to different regions
of the transcriptome
and so with that methodology in mind of
combining all of these guide sets
together to be able to effectively
redistribute reads we've implemented an
insilico depletion of 14 publicly
available SRA 10x data sets and tested
this to see is it if it's a viable
option as a result what we showed here
is that if we combine our ribosomal RNA
and our ribomito and again ribomino
meaning are polyadenylated ribosomal and
mitochondrial genes if we combine that
together we can redistribute
approximately 42 percent of reads which
is something that we did previously
which we showed previously however what
we want to also do is Implement these
unaligned reads that are aligned to the
genome but being filtered out as well as
these non-variable genes and if we do it
in silicone depletion and apply these
same principles or these depletion we
can redistribute up to 50 percent of
reads being aligned to the transcriptome
which in turn allows us to get more
transcript information
and so in order app now that we've done
our in-silocode depletion have our proof
of principle that we can actually Target
these genes to redistribute reads we
want to show showcase this in terms of
how we can actually do this in the
context of pbmcs to identify new cell
types so we performing this in
triplicates so we have three different
channels being run with pbmcs on the 10x
chip
from there we take our Amplified cdna at
the WTA step we take that and we split
it equally between our control which is
therefore going to be proceeding with
the standard 10x workflow or our
depletion as a result we're able to
directly compare from the same channel
the differences between the control and
depleted in triplicates as a result
and after afterwards we have obtained
our final libraries and proceed with
sequence sequencing and downstream
analysis
and next what we want to focus on here
is show how the depletion after we
proceed with the 10x workflow the
standard and then depleted and we
proceed with sequencing how we're
actually able to double the amount of
informative transcriptional reads so
very beautifully we can see if we look
at the pie chart in blue and the control
we look at our informative
transcriptional information and we
compare that with the depleted we're
actually almost we're actually doubling
or having 100 increase in the in the
Reese mapped to the transcriptome with
the crisper clean depletion that's being
aligned in formative transcript
information whereas non-informative
transcript information would be your
um ribosome one mitochondrial
protein coding genes or your
non-variable genes
and now if you remember what we did with
the endothelial samples you can see
remember that we sequenced to
approximately about 57 000 reads per
cell which is a lot of reads per cell so
you might be asking yourself well could
just be that you know your sequence is
such a high sequencing depth however
with this saturation plot we really want
to highlight the point that across
sequencing depth the depletion is able
to increase the number of umis per cell
and approximately by almost two times so
one and a half times as much right and
even in this case with the pbmc samples
that we're using at a sequencing depth
of approx approximately 25 000 reads per
cell we're still able to recover more
genes per cell more umines and more
genes contributing to biological signals
suggesting that as a researcher
depending on what your sequencing
capabilities are with depletion you're
able to get much more breadth of
coverage as a result
and again one of our main goals here is
to highlight how we can identify
different cell types using this
technology and so what we want to show
here is that we're using a cell
annotation tool for pvmcs that were done
automatically from predefined Legacy
markers so the reason we're showing this
here is because we want to highlight the
fact that we're not manually annotating
these cell types by ourselves right the
key here is that we're using markers
from a published repository containing
over a million pbmc
pbmcs and again and this algorithm takes
into effect genes that are specifically
up and down regulated as well as the
frequency of abundance so again just to
highlight the fact that when we're
identifying cell types here in these
pbmcs we're using an automatic tool in
an unsupervised fashion so that we can
eliminate as much human interference as
possible for an unbiased result
and so sequencing approximately 12 000
pbmc cells again at approximately 25
000 reads per cell we can see that if we
compare the U map plus between the
control and the depleted what I've
highlighted here for you on the left in
the control is a cell type population
that is in the that is not being
identified in the control that is being
identified and depleted but if we just
focus on the control right now we can
see these two arms that are branching
off of these cd14 positive monocytes but
are not being but are not being labeled
by this automatic annotation tool has a
different cell type however with
depletion by redistributing those reads
we are actually able to increase the
euclidean distance of these of these
branches and as a result get a different
interpretation as well as and identify
two additional cell types one being a
cd16 positive monocyte as well as a rare
population of cd1 C positive dendritic
cells again just adding to the notion
that we're able to identify more rare
cell types as well as more cell types
that we are not able to accurately
identify in the control that we're able
to capture in the depleted samples
and so what I'm highlighting here is
that we're actually implementing another
way of doing an unsupervised cell
clustering method that's using deep
learning so before we use an automatic
cell annotation tool but here we're even
taking even more human influence out of
the equation and using a deep learning
algorithm to automatically do the
clustering to see if we can actually in
a completely unbiased way see if we
still see the same result and confirm
whether or not we see additional cell
types in the depleted versus the control
and again the main takeaway here so
rather than using a umap plus is using T
sneeze plots again doing the same goal
just taking
um transcriptional landscape and
representing in two-dimensional space
for cell cluster we can see that in the
pbmcs for the control we're only
identifying nine clusters whereas we're
identifying an additional two clusters
in the with the depletion and what I've
highlighted here is the areas that are
being
divided up into different clusters so
that arm of cell cluster one on this in
the control is now being
divided up into cell cluster 4 and the
in the depleted and cell cluster 6 and
the control is being further divided up
into five and six and in the depleted
um just aiding to the fact that you know
we're increasing the euclidean distance
of these clusters and accurately
representing
um the the different cell types that
existing within these populations
here this algorithm also has a way of
assigning probabilities to these
different cell types and so what we want
to show here is that assigning these
cell types was relatively high
probability where lighter colors so
yellow meaning a low probability and the
darker the purple the higher probability
that it is the cell type so we can see
if we look at that specifically that one
arm structure and the control we can see
that it's with a very low probability a
relatively low probability of being
assigned that cluster however after
redistributing the reads with depletion
we're actually able to assign it with a
much higher probability that yes this is
indeed an additional cell type adding to
our confidence here that the result that
we are seeing is in fact real
and finally one last question we want to
answer is if can we sequence less but
recover the same information using
crispr clean digestion now if you
remember briefly what we showed before
is that with with this crispr clean
digestion with the protocol we're
actually able to double the amount of
transcriptional reads at the same
sequencing depth but
can we sequence half as much but still
retain the same amount of information
and what's very nicely shown here is how
with um how we're able to detect the
same number of genes in umized per cell
with half the amount of reads per cell
in a depleted sample so if you take our
undepleted sample and if we'd say we're
sequencing at a depth of approximately
27 000 reads per cell
and we take that and use our crispr
clean depletion in half so if we only
deplete to half the sequencing depth of
13 500 reads per cell what we can see is
that the
um the genes per cell is is
approximately the same so in an
undepleted sample at a very sequencing
depth of 27 000 range per cell the
amount of genes per cell you recover is
1353 whereas with the crisper clean
depleted it's 13 140. so roughly about
half the sequencing depth and you retain
about the same number of genes per cell
and approximately the same number of um
per shelf suggesting that
um you can do a two for one sequencing
as a result so you can sequence twice as
much and for the same price
now how does that actually affect our
biological interpretation at sequencing
half the depth now while we're still
retaining the same number of uh genes
and umis per cell at half the depth do
we actually contain still biologically
the same relevant information and what
we see here is very strikingly that half
the reason depletion is still able to
recover two additional cell types so if
we look at that t Snee Plus or the umap
plot rather that we showed previously if
we have highlighted here this population
of cd14 positive monocytes and those two
arms coming off of it
those additional those arms are now
being identified as two new cell types
right and that's because we've
redistributed those reads and get a
better and as a result when it does to
cell clustering it's able to get a
better
um representation of those being
different cell types by increasing the
euclidean distance between them as a
result we are now identifying again a
cd16 positive monocyte as well as a cd1
c positive dendritic cell rarer cell
type population with the depleted sample
at half the C at half the sequencing
depth
in summary here I would like to
highlight how crispr clean single cell
RNA boost kit is generally able to
increase the number of genes in your
homage per cell as well as increase our
informative reason in pbmc samples as
well as identified additional cell types
additionally one great thing about this
is that we're able to recover the same
information at half the number of
sequencing grades so as a researcher
you're able to use your researching
dollars more more wisely
and effectively do a two for one
sequencing as a result
and finally just to drive the point home
here in conclusion our depletion is able
to recover more information as well as
increase the signal to noise and
statistically enhance our biological
interpretation for any Downstream
analysis that we have and have more
confidence in our results as researchers
I would like to thank jump code genomics
for giving the opportunity to work on
such a great project as well as the
pande lab for the for the endothelial
samples he could be so commonly provided
as well as description genomics core for
allowing us to use their sequencing
technology and platforms now I will
stick around for anybody that has any
questions and I look forward to hearing
from each of you
thank you
thank you Dante for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
so let's get started our first question
is
does the crispr clean reaction use all
the cdna from my 10x prep
uh yeah so first I would like to say and
thanks for you know having me and
um letting you present but to answer
that question
um the answer to that is uh no it does
not use all the reaction from the cdna
from the 10x preps so we've optimized
the protocol to work with the 10x
standard where you take one quarter or
one-fourth of the existing library and
then proceed with the depletion in that
case so yeah
all right thank you
our next question does crispr clean
depletion introduce bias to my gene
expression readout
yeah so when we incorporate our
depletion protocol into the into the
library prep we do it after the adapter
ligation step after the cdna has been
Amplified
um and by doing so we can effectively
remove a lot of the PCR duplicates that
exist in the library as a result so
that's what we're depleting to try and
get more unique molecules and more
unique genes in our libraries
um so as a result when we take when we
take that deduplicated library and we
plot it into control versus depleted we
get an r squared value of approximately
you know 0.99 it's a very significant so
by doing so we don't introduce any bias
into the
um as a result from depletion
great thank you
compatible with the five Prime chromium
assay and what about visium spatial
yeah so we've actually done experiments
and we've actually optimized it as well
to be able to work with those different
platforms that 10x offers with the five
Prime chromium as well as the vision
spatials so any libraries that you
generate
um with with either of those protocols
we have shown that depletion can work uh
can work with it and specifically
especially for the visium that's
something we're really excited about and
um currently working more on right now
to be able to have like a you know
people to push something more into the
market but
um but yeah as to the short answer yes
we have it is compatible and we have
shown that it can be depleted with the
libraries generated from those protocols
as well
all right
and next question where can I find
detailed information on this kit
yeah so if you would like to find so we
have all of our information on our
website at jumpco genomics.com and then
also you can reach out to our sales team
at sales at junk code genomics as well
if you would like to and I believe in
the presentation there's also some links
that um you know you can you can look to
for the reaching out to the sales team
or for our website for where you can
find more product information here
we are going to wrap up with that
question
um thank you Dante do you have any final
comments for our audience
no I just look again if anybody has any
questions or concerns you'll feel free
to you can email me at
dante.dante.di jumpco genomics.com or
email our sales team if you have any
specific questions but again on our
website we have all of that publicly
available data
um and as well as all the data we've
generated thus far so if you really want
to know more about our product please
make sure to go to our website and
contact our sales team as well
well thank you again Dante for your time
today and your important research before
we go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions I'd also like to
thank our sponsors jumpco genomics for
sponsoring today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until April 21st 2024.
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye